[Música]
esperarían que nuestro sistema
inmunológico está preparado para
producir defensas llamadas anticuerpos
contra cualquier bichito que infecta en
nuestro cuerpo pero hay dichos de bichos
hay bichitos infecciosos conocidos desde
hace mucho que son transmitidos por
bichos molestos como los zancudos y hay
otros bichos que dan miedo como las
serpientes que nos pueden morder e
inyectar las toxinas que dañan nuestros
tejidos y a veces aparecen nuevos bichos
infecciosos que son transmitidos
directamente entre los seres humanos
como éste tal corona virus que agrava
anda por todo lado nuestro sistema
inmunológico puede producir anticuerpos
contra más de mil millones de
estructuras los anticuerpos son
maravillosos están hechos a la medida de
blancos específicos y nos ayudan a
defender nuestro organismo cuando llega
una toxina o un bichito de esos que nos
pueden infectar pero el asunto es que es
como son hechos a la medida primer lo
primero que necesita el sistema
inmunológico para producirlos es
identificar y aprender a reconocer el
molde contra el que están dirigidos
se requieren de una a dos semanas para
fabricar grandes cantidades de
anticuerpos contra una toxina o un
bichito invasor y enviarlos a la sangre
para que se distribuyan por todo el
cuerpo y nos protejan el problema es que
para ganar las luchas nuestro sistema
inmunológico necesita tiempo y a veces
no hay suficiente tiempo por ejemplo
cuando una serpiente nos muerde porque
las serpientes muerden y no pican como
dice mucha gente nos inyecta una
cantidad enorme de toxinas que pueden
destruir nuestros tejidos y producir nos
la muerte en cuestión de horas y nuestro
sistema inmunológico no puede producir
anticuerpos contra esas toxinas en esas
pocas horas y entonces qué podemos hacer
pues podemos tomar anticuerpos prestados
de otros animales
y lo que hay que hacer es inyectarle
esas toxinas
y esperar a que su sistema inmune
produzca anticuerpos que se purifican en
una planta farmacéutica para la
producción de medicamentos inyectables
los antivenenos o sueros antiofídicos
contienen anticuerpos de caballos contra
las toxinas de serpientes que están
listos para ser inyectados en la sangre
de las personas que están mordidas
esos anticuerpos se purifican de la
sangre de animales a los que se les han
inyectado pequeñas cantidades de veneno
repetidamente por meses o años entonces
el sistema inmunológico de estos
caballos es una fábrica permanente de
anticuerpos a la medida para bloquear
las toxinas de esos venenos
más de dos millones y medio de seres
humanos cada año en todo el mundo tienen
el infortunio de ser mordidos por
serpientes imagínense como la mitad de
la población de costa rica y lo más
triste es que muchísimas de esas
personas no tienen acceso al tratamiento
con sueros antiofídicos y como
consecuencia según la organización
mundial de la salud se estima que más de
100 mil personas mueren cada año y más
de 400.000 personas quedan con terribles
secuelas de por vida como las
amputaciones de las extremidades
los sueros antiofídicos aunque son
medicamentos esenciales escasean en
muchos países porque no hay quien los
produzca y esto por muchos años
pareciera que no le importaba a nadie
pues la mayor parte de la gente que
tiene el problema de mordeduras de
serpientes son campesinos en países en
vías de desarrollo es decir gente pobre
en países pobres y las grandes compañías
farmacéuticas saben muy bien que
producir medicamentos para gente pobre
en países pobres no es un buen negocio
por eso no producen sueros antiofídicos
en costa rica la historia ha sido
distinta afortunadamente hace 50 años
personas visionarias unieron talentos e
hicieron posible que nuestro país
produjéramos los sueros antiofídicos que
necesitamos se creó el instituto
clodomiro picado de la universidad de
costa rica por década la universidad ha
invertido recursos en investigaciones
para desarrollar una plataforma robusta
para la producción de sueros
antiofídicos y por eso es que hoy somos
autosuficientes
eso de no depender de otros para el
abastecimiento de medicamentos
esenciales como los sueros antiofídicos
es una buena noticia en asuntos de salud
pública y si ser autosuficiente de
medicamentos esenciales en tiempo
normales es bueno pareciera que es mucho
más importante aún en tiempos de
pandemia cuando una infección se propaga
simultáneamente en varios continentes
como ha pasado ya varias veces en los
últimos 100 años
este nuevo coronavirus que está causando
la pandemia actual se expandió
rápidamente por todo el mundo nos
sorprendió y nos ha hecho iguales no
distingue entre sexo edad condición
económica nos afecta a todas las
personas países muy poderosos y países
muy chiquitos todos estamos buscando
cómo enfrentarlo para que el número de
enfermos y de personas que mueren sea el
menor posible pero mejor les voy a
contar un cuento se acuerdan de la
fábula de la cigarra y la hormiga
aquella en que en tiempos de bonanza las
llegaran a olga sana y criticona
mientras que la hormiga era es forzada y
trabajadora y que la hormiga tomó las
previsiones para almacenar los alimentos
en los tiempos de crisis bueno lo que
les voy a contar en la historia de cómo
costa rica fue la hormiga trabajadora
antes de esta pandemia
en nuestra pequeña costa rica desde que
llegó este coronavirus lo hemos podido
enfrentar aprovechando la inversión en
salud y educación que nos legaron
nuestros abuelos y que se ha ido
enriqueciendo con el tiempo contar con
instituciones robustas como el
ministerio de salud la caja
costarricense del seguro social y las
universidades públicas ha sido
fundamental y en la búsqueda de un nuevo
tratamiento para los infectados por
coronavirus ocurrió algo que vale la
pena contar desde la caja del seguro
surgió la propuesta de que generaremos
una solución aprovechando lo que hemos
invertido para hacer autosuficientes
produciendo sueros antiofídicos y que
usáramos el sistema inmune de caballos
para producir anticuerpos a la medida de
coronavirus inyectándoles en lugar de
venenos algunas partes del del virus
esos anticuerpos contra el coronavirus
podrían ser inyectados a los pacientes
para ayudarles a ganar la lucha contra
este nuevo visito qué buena idea y
entonces juntos como país dimos un paso
al frente
algunos estudiando un poco más y
trabajando tiempo extra y otros dijeron
yo pongo los caballos y otros yo pongo
el equipo yo aporto a este o aquel otro
recurso y así con el esfuerzo y los
aportes de varias instituciones del
gobierno
muchas personas construimos un proyecto
que ya casi da sus frutos pues ya en
costa rica hay caballos produciendo
anticuerpos contra este coronavirus ya
los sangramos y empezamos la
purificación de los anticuerpos
esperamos tener en menos de un mes un
suero anti coronavirus listo para tratar
a los pacientes con esta terrible
infección
y aunque esta historia todavía no
termina lo que definitivamente claro es
claro con este proyecto es que si vale
la pena ser como la hormiga y tomar
previsiones para los tiempos de crisis
haber invertido en la educación e
investigación hizo la diferencia para
costa rica y eso de contar con una
fábrica para hacer anticuerpos a la
medida de cualquier creo que es
una gran ventaja para la salud pública
en tiempos de pandemia
todos somos parte de este país
chiquitito que puede hacer las cosas
diferentes y con este proyecto se hizo
evidente que todos los esfuerzos cuentan
en épocas de crisis todas y todos
tenemos algo que aportar al bien de la
colectividad no sabemos si seremos de
las personas afortunadas que
sobrevivirán y de aquellas que no tengan
un ser querido que llorar
cuidémonos hagamos nuestro aporte desde
donde estemos y no desfallezcamos que
aún queda mucho camino por recorrer
tenemos que creérnoslo trabajar duro y
con espíritu solidario yo creo que si
todas y todos ponemos de nuestra parte
si vamos a poder salir de esta crisis
seamos como la hormiga trabajemos y
contribuyamos a la búsqueda de
soluciones en vez de criticar como la
cigarra esta historia no ha terminado en
nuestras manos está darle un buen final
[Aplausos]
[Música]
cómo